une respiration deux artistes qui
s'associent l'un des musiciens l'autre
peintre leur projet anima souffle en
latin nos sources d'inspiration c'est
beaucoup les choses beaucoup de choses
comment dire ancestrale antique les
peuples d'origine ça peut être les
natifs les indiens natifs d'amérique ça
pète
il ya un truc sur lequel on se retrouve
vachement on appelle ça des danses
indiennes et c'est quand manu faire des
poussées des personnages qui sont en
train de danser avec quelque chose de
chamanique de tribal de spirituel
l'impression d'être deux petits sagouin
qui parle des racines de l'humanité des
tribus de ces choses là alors qu'on
connaît pas ça dans ma vie mais on a
l'impression que ça résonne
une page blanche pour emmanuel brodeau
un micro et un ordinateur pour philippe
thuillier
leur performance est une oeuvre unique
créée autour d'un maître mot
l'improvisation
une fois que le départ est lancé après
ça s'arrête plus on sait on sait pas où
on va mais par contre c'est maintenant
on sait ce qui se passe maintenant et
cette peinture et là des allers retours
des courbes et philippe avec la musique
à une vibration on essaye de connecter 7
7 7 vibrations de la musique et de la
peinture en même temps c'est l'heure
pour dire la même chose des coulures de
peinture qui dansent sur la feuille au
rythme de la musique des visages qui se
forment un instant suspendu
[Musique]